tori is with us in uh celina kansas hi
tori welcome to the ramsay show
hello sirs how are you doing today
better than we deserve what's up in your
world
excellent well um so two times in the
last
probably three years i feel like god
has been nudging me to become a nurse
these
the idea of wow i should be a nurse i
shouldn't be doing what i'm doing
has hit me just out of the blue and it
hit me
most recently at a funeral i was at
so and then a little bit of backstory um
the company that i work for i'm actually
one of the owners i'm a shareholder all
that kind of stuff
we do home care and they have graciously
said
that they will pay for me to go through
nursing school because
one of the owners who is you know our
company rn
is is older than i am and going to
retire you know at some point so the
thought is that i would just take
their place when they retire um
i'm i'm calling because i'm very new in
my christian walk and i
have respected you uh for years
and and you know being very god-led
and so i'm wondering you know what i
should do
and how old are you you know the finance
i'm
i'm uh 33. excellent that's a great
question thank you for honoring us with
that
a question that's sensitive anthony yeah
you know tori i think one of the things
that i hear
from you is uh let me ask this question
real quickly
why do you think god is calling like why
are you so passionate about it why do
you think god is telling you
this is what you need to do other than
what you
may think yeah so
um the first time that it hit me and it
was just it was just like a mental thing
like what are you doing with your life
you're supposed to be a nurse it was i'm
driving on my way to work at a
at a pass job and i saw a lady in scrubs
walking down the street
and then you know i didn't really think
much of it beyond that because
it didn't really apply to me then but
the one that happened most recently
i was you know at this amazing woman's
funeral
she was actually a client of ours and
you know i was there for support for
family of course and also for our our
caregivers
and again you know no no nursing really
related and it just
hit me as i was getting a little bit
emotional about um
her granddaughter's actually speech at
her funeral
and i was like what am i doing with my
life like this this
isn't what i've been called to do first
and foremost there's not a perfect
system yeah uh you know
and i've been walking with god a long
time and sometimes i find out it was
last night's pizza talking to me not the
holy spirit so um
you just you just don't always know for
sure until you look back right
and you look back and you go well that
was not god it's a disaster back there
and he doesn't he doesn't sign us up for
those or that was god
so i use three or four things one
is you need to have a peace when you
start talking about this does your soul
relax the peace that surpasses all
understanding the bible calls it or do
you feel angst
if you feel angst it's probably not god
the second thing i look for
is circumstantial things because god
will align things he runs everything
he's there five years from now
he's there five years ago and he's here
now at the same time he's not bound by
time
and so he's lining things up and you've
got some circumstantial things lining up
here
that make a lot of sense and the third
thing i ask myself is what is this thing
i'm hearing
does it align with scripture
for instance i believe in my study of
the bible for 40 years
that the bible does not say debt is a
good idea
and so if i've got to go into debt to do
it i'm thinking that's not god
because it doesn't align with scripture
or if it involves
uh you doing something else that's you
know more blatantly even against
scripture obviously being a nurse a
caregiver would be a very godly thing to
do
it's a wonderful thing to do so if those
three things are lined up
the only other thing i heard which is
beautiful i know that visiting brand new
babies when they're born
and going to funerals these are the
tuning forks of life
this is when you stop your everyday
grind and you're looking
at a casket or you're looking at a brand
new baby and you get
retuned to the lord retuned
to where god's taking you it's a tuning
fork it sets you back in place
and so the fact that goes down a funeral
home kind of gives me inspiration too
i think it's him but i don't i could be
wrong we're just talking it through
together
uh you don't have to get too spooky
about it you can just go be a nurse
hey you want to add anything to that how
to hear
god's voice discussion because you i
mean you pastored you
young people you were a youth pastor for
many years yeah i'd be interested to
hear your further take on that we got
pinched by the commercial a little bit
oh yeah
dave i think he was hitting it right on
i think one of the things that you said
that resonates with me
so well is when i know i hear from god
at least
90 of it is when i can align what i
hear with god's word and what i've
learned is god is really never silent
we're just not listening and when we're
not listening it's because we're not
really
in in the word we're not really studying
and getting connected and getting closer
to him
so for me i tend to say that was god was
in my emotions when i wasn't
really reading but when i'm reading when
i'm when i'm listening
god is talking and when he's silent
that's still god talking
and so for me uh when you said it has to
align with the word of god
uh that resonated with me so much
because if i say that i hear something
i'm hearing it through the word
and that's that's that resonated for me
dave yeah my counsel would be don't move
on a singular
spiritual event right there should be
more than
there should be confirmation in your
spirit confirmation circumstances but
i had a dream and i woke up that morning
and i'm gonna go do it no no
that's a dream yeah well it could it
could be god right
but if it is there's gonna be more
evidence than just that
yes over a period of weeks or months or
years yeah
and it may be a timing thing yeah you
know and so
uh you know you you singular
events uh can you're more likely to make
a mistake and miss
whether it's really him or not off of a
singular event but if you can get more
than one data point
as you're walking through that then you
know uh
like you said one another data point is
it aligns with the word of god another
data point is
the circumstantial thing lined up and
then another and then another time i'm
driving down the street there's a lady
in scrubs and i hear
hear this voice again saying this in my
mind and then you know i get that but i
don't uh
come in here after my prayer time
and um in 30 years maybe two times
and say god told me something this
morning we're going to do this oh man
we just say you know okay i'm gonna just
pause right here and make sure that's
not last night's pizza yeah yeah
you know i believe from our our
spiritual belief
i mean if god says this is what he wants
you to do he's gonna also give you the
resources to do it and he got and he did
he gave him the
pain they're paying for exactly to be a
nurse that was awesome so that's
another big confirmation right there
yeah yeah like hey that
that could be it sounds like god oh
preacher said the definition of
prosperity
is having the money to do what god says
to do yep
and if that's a big thing it gives you
all that if it's a little thing you'll
give you that
yeah that's uh that's a that's a sure
sign that's a great discussion you guys
it's um um in a world called crazy
we need to talk about stuff like this
more and it'll calm some of you people
down some of you people are out of
control out there
oh my gosh calm get off social media
till you grow up
well that just means you won't okay